boom hello everyone what's up what's up
my name is Alan Saki and I'm the host of
simulation today we have the pleasure of
sitting down with Stu simmer and hello
there what's up Alan and brother yeah
good to be here with you this is gonna
be a blast Stu's definitely one of my
favorite people he is raising the
vibrational frequency of humanity and
getting people more conscious through
all of his endeavors and so I'm really
excited to bring him onto simulation
we're really excited to have a good
conversation Stu's the co-host of get
conscious now for five years now just
about yeah yeah and so um and then he's
also the chief emanation officer the CEO
of only the source it has been about a
year and a half or so that's a
transformational media company so maybe
we chat a little bit about get conscious
now what that's about
and yeah that the name yeah just now
know exactly which is a little bit of a
tricky name only because there's nothing
outside of us to get yeah and it's
really about exploring one the true
nature of our physical reality and two
how can we live a more mindful life
which of course with the true nature of
our reality tends to be more connected
more peaceful more loving and ultimately
much more playful yes let's go to the
first thing that you said there's
nothing to get outside yes so it's all
inside all inward so we close our eyes
we take a breath
and we really can feel everything that's
going on within us and what we can
maximize our self to be what else what
else can we get from this so yeah yeah
yeah so in going inward and there this
old kind of line out there that says
that you know ask and you shall receive
and with curiosity if we really explore
what is really true what is really going
on here starting with myself and one of
the questions I ask myself regularly and
maybe you do - do I have a choice
it's that simple because most of us are
on this automatic pilot based upon all
of our prior experiences the beliefs
preferences we have our own kind of each
of us has our own idea of what's going
on which is frequently based upon
limited filters and so in asking the
first question do I have a choice in
this moment do I need to respond the
same way as I would if I were on
autopilot just in simply asking the
question the answer is typically
actually I do have a choice and that's a
great place to start okay so where would
that choice then lead us to the choice
of maybe turning inward and under
introspection and understand yourself
better the choice of what sandwich to
get at the deli where are we yeah where
are we at with this toy it there are
multiple ways to look at it let's say
you know I'm about you but I think
relationship is perhaps one of the last
frontiers you know it's like you think
you're conscious or awake or enlightened
spent some time with your family or
spent some time with your beloved and
isn't it incredible how whatever buttons
and woundings and things need to be
healed you know these people who we
invite in to be closest with us
this uncanny knack of binding those
buttons yeah you know and even though
they're the closest ones to us maybe
especially because I see exactly because
we allow them in and we invite in that
extra layer of intimacy ability exactly
exactly know us for a longer period of
time our mom or our dad definitely does
her brother or sister doesn't than our
intimate partner for sure I mean that's
almost 24 hours a day with in the same
bed and all that stuff as that right so
when things come up and maybe a sore
spot is hit you know what happens well
if we pay attention we probably noticed
that we begin to breathe a little more
shallow and a little more rapid our our
body heat tends to take a couple of
notches on me right and so that's our
body's way of telling us you know what
I'm not happy with this moment okay but
it doesn't mean that we have to go into
our patterns yes
that typically sabotage or recur and
keep us in a loop preventing us from
experiencing what we'd really like and
using the body as a great as a great
metric for discerning where we are in a
given moment we can say or look at gee
maybe it's best that I just simply take
a step back for a moment maybe to
breathe maybe to move a little bit yeah
get a glass of water something to help
this shift the energy a little bit to
see if we can have a different outcome
to what otherwise is a repeating pattern
that may not serve us so much yes so
there's a couple things there the first
thing brings me to meditation to what's
been practiced for thousands of years
and actually have been recently learning
about something called the Lindy effect
which initially Nassim Taleb
introduced me to which is that things
that have been around for a longer
period of time typically end up staying
around for a longer period of things
that have been around a short period of
time tend to go really quickly away from
us fast there so for example things like
maybe the wheel has been around a really
long time yeah gonna be around a long
time it's just one of those things right
this this glass the shape of this
container for liquids or even for
storage and caring has been around
really long time things like maybe the
Bible and religion or things like
meditation has been around such a long
time so I kind of like versus maybe
snapchat ray has been around whatever
five years and people right and it might
be gone in five years probably yeah
exactly
yeah so so um so when it comes to
something like meditation I'm like kind
of bouncing around in Silicon Valley and
going meditate it's thousands of years
old meditate you know and it'll help so
much reduce suffering and so you know
when you bring that up for me in the
terms of a relationship especially
there's so many different things that we
can do to to change the energy when when
would you say it's appropriate to try
and maybe take a breath and stay in the
same energy and try and solve it versus
maybe say I'm gonna go get a glass of
tea I'm gonna go and stretch a little
I'm gonna go change my energy and come
back that decision can sometimes be
difficult to know when that's right
right so we get to play with it a little
bit ultimately you know rumor has it you
can't make a wrong decision and so a lot
of a lot of trial and error here there
is no you know life this is more of an
art than it is a science by many
measures and what we're looking at now
in terms of things like breathing sound
movement they have been around since the
beginning of time that have shifted
energy in all kinds of different
disciplines where I think people hop off
and kind of you know push it away is
because if it comes with any kind of
dogma or if it comes with any other
kinds of shoulds and shouldn't or this
way is better than that way yeah if you
do it that way you're not doing it right
and depending on who I am you made to go
into hell too yeah so I'm just saying
that that is something that even though
that's been around a long time that is
actually starting to become less
effective in our approach and looking at
it more through science through the lens
of science to engage the rational mind
yeah and some curiosity to say okay if
it's really true that there's a quantum
field of energy that is ever present in
all things then 99.999999 repeating
percent of physical existence is wave
and the balance point zero zero zero
zero zero or one percent is matter
that's the real true nature of things
then scientifically if somebody asks you
what the matter what's the matter the
scientific answer is not much because
we're really wave here so to have that
kind of curiosity that even though our
entire lives have been based on i'm
individual i'm separate from you i'm
separate from you and definitely
separate from the people in Africa Egypt
you know Europe and everywhere else and
perhaps even our president you know on
another level if I understand at least
cognitively that there is a unified
field that we're all a part of is that
worth exploring and if it is what are
the implications with using some of
these age-old tools and apply it perhaps
in a slightly different and definitely
not dogmatic exactly that's such a key
that you bring up the dogma I know it
seems like it's holding us back it's all
that dogma especially within the last
couple thousand years with religion and
that that's been my way is right my
school of thought is right in many ways
has been a prom even with things like
science this science is right this blank
is right my philosophy is right and that
seems also to be something with
meditation like you're saying that maybe
not isn't right thing to be prancing
around being like meditate meditate
meditate cuz people will just be like
what if I do what happens if I don't
meditate then what and and then that's
when right can be like well what about
why is your meditation the best what
about mindfulness that can be better and
so then so then it doesn't actually
become you know optimized down to one
thing that people can do there's all
these different ways like you said
dancing singing non moving breathing all
these different kind of ways that we can
dance through the world and experience
that art form of living okay so we're
gonna end up unpacking so much of this
so that so okay so get conscious now has
been going on for a while we'll put the
link in the bio for you guys to check
out and then only the source has started
up the last year and a half yes
and tell us a little bit about only the
source great thank you yeah this is
definitely my raison d'être I know I'm
not gonna gun French I'm sorry I raised
on death by means reason for being
raised on death row yeah reason for
being it's like life Columbus and I am
absolutely in fact you know so we are a
trance trance formation 'el media
company and our tagline is the next
human oh s yes where the OS is both an
operating system and it redoes refer
back to only source as the new OS the
old OS we kind of lightheartedly refer
to as original sin which is really
nothing more than a story of separation
from vac which is infinite all of a
sudden there's a sense of individuality
I am separate from that and I'm somehow
ashamed in my imperfection okay and all
of our systems are based on that notion
of separation
and it's showing up in every area
whether it's in economics and a wide
divide of income and wealth distribution
it's showing up in politics with this
wide divide right and within our own
country so even the term United States
isn't exactly a current one because not
one state is united but alone all of our
states being united that's the real
truth of it yeah and it goes towards
economics it goes towards legal system
education even the family systems it's
okay to love my lineage unconditionally
but everybody else has to earn it
you know so all of those systems are
based in separation and with a new OS
which is based on quantum physics that
there's a unified field whatever it's
called energy the universe we call it
source for lack of a better word it's
also an open source and that because
it's infinite and ever-present there are
infinite ways to awaken to that which is
already inside of us and all around us
so as you just mentioned infinite ways
the weak infinite so it's an open source
literally yeah that's where all the
dogma doesn't work exactly that's where
Dogma breaks down that's where guru
breaks down yeah because you know the
Guru's God bless them you know they tend
to be put on a pedestal yeah that's just
another form of separation where I'm not
worthy or guru do this for me because
it's easier than my doing it myself you
know correct and so that's just another
thing that this really does it
completely democratizes and levels the
playing field that each one of us are
every bit no more or no less an aspect
of this source energy yeah than anybody
else yeah that that's so good so so
feels good it feels so good it feels so
right now I must ask there are lots of
people that feel like individualism and
the vigil allottee is so crucial as well
that does create separation as a meet
and they I see that I feel it um but but
also knowing how to tap into the
collective at the same time into that
unified theory of quantum physics and
understanding how to ride the different
waves with people and how you're not
them you're us we're us right so where
do you kind of stand with people wanting
to have individualism but also yeah yeah
so let's consider a blizzard of snow so
you've got this massive snowdrift made
up of individual snowflakes all of which
having their own unique imprint
we're both it's like you know or ocean
where it's both the drop of water and
the wave body and on one level it's all
interconnected
and we're all one in that regard and on
another level leaf in the tree the blade
of grass and the lawn exactly exactly
whatever metaphor you want to use it's
all the same the snowflakes especially
because each one is different that well
that's why I use that good versus water
droplet yeah yeah yeah but that's it's a
good one yeah the blizzard and the
snowflake yeah okay yeah so and taking
this to further you know isn't it a
blessing that there is this degree of
call it unique individualization even as
we're all interconnected so that's a
blessing with it with the converse being
if we were all identical
maybe life wouldn't be so interesting no
no okay so so the individuality of the
snowflake but the collectivist
understanding of the blizzard
okay I like that I think that can
resonate enough with people you can be
your interviewee please we want that
actually we need that yeah that inspires
us to be our individual selves and there
and there is this other aspect called
mystery okay that we can all be humble
too but there is something going on here
that maybe we never get fully to the
bottom of there is this mystery in terms
of why does this universe even exist
what is this source trying to accomplish
through its creation of us and all the
the cycle of life and all the other
species out here what is it doing you
know we will get to that at the end of
the box okay I look for this thing to
myself yeah exactly and maybe we'll
never know but it's um but it's very
fascinating to dance through life trying
to figure it out I love that and I
really like the blizzard that's that's a
good one individualism we need you we
need you to be fully self actualized and
individually but also part of the
greater understanding of the unification
of all of us yeah I recently I heard
this and I thought it was so interesting
that it will take the discovery of
aliens to understand that we are all one
tribe on earth I've seen yeah I've heard
that that that's them what would it take
right what would it take for us to come
together because you know I remember
watching Star Trek and stuff they never
had oh these are the yeah the Republican
Vulcans and these are the you know
Democrat Vulcans and they can't stand
each other
they were always unified within their
own planet yeah they may not have like
the Romulans yeah but you know but they
were all interconnected as one species
and I found that really interesting and
so yeah I mean there is nothing like a
common enemy to unite us all yeah you
know which is kind of odd yeah in a
strange way it is very very strange way
and maybe one day we'll even have
galactic love like galactic tribal is
yeah together working right so let's
just start with some so we'll unpack
some things of only the source as we go
and so let's let's talk
we've already chatted about vibration
and energetics and carrying these juicy
vibes maybe we talk about this because
this is something you brought up that I
think it's important to address is
ushering out the old OS and in the new
OS is that's a that's a good way to look
at it I think but then there's also the
what can we keep from the old OS and
bring it into what we're building with
the new OS is that fair to say that
we're gonna keep some things from the
old OS and maybe what are those things
well that's a good question and I'd love
to tell you that I have all the answers
to it I don't one thing I am pretty
certain about is that as we allow our
own individual and collective
integration into a new OS which is a
vibration of greater delight greater
ease greater playfulness greater
connectedness it becomes its own self
organizing principle yeah and if the
vibrational presence that decides picks
and chooses let's keep this thank you
very much old news there and that's how
we get to evolve so I wish I could tell
you that I know exactly how it's because
the real truth is it has implications
for every aspect of civilization and I
I'm really humble and curious to see how
it went unfold other than to say I would
imagine that there would be a greater
baseline for human existence
because of our interconnectedness all
that we really need is a little bit of
will and everybody has clean water
everybody has healthy food access and
potentially and this may sound really
bold free energy correct energy you know
and so that I see are some of the
natural consequences
now what would have to happen for that
to occur and what kind of evolution
would the petroleum industry need to
undergo go as one example and and the
coca-cola industry and exactly exactly
and even the political frameworks and
the governments how would they evolve to
allow for this kind of transition is is
kind of curious to see how it would
happen and I do sense it can happen in
ways that that are really graceful yeah
yeah yeah and that's really important is
the grace that that the transitional
grace through that period Ron is this is
this on point or what this evolution I
love it it does seem like it's the
natural trajectory of our evolution but
it's gonna be tough to I'm Ron and I
talked about this from all the time it's
tough to get the governments and the
politics all gracefully in order and the
corporation's the petroleum industry and
coca-cola it's gonna be difficult so
let's use this metaphor okay of and
you've probably heard it before for the
caterpillar and the butterfly right so
they're these things inside the
caterpillar called imaginal cells right
that basically have the initial imprint
of the butterfly at some point in its
metamorphosis these cells start to
activate you speak so beautifully it's
this beautiful happen well thank you the
picture
Industries of Caterpillar one day it's
gonna turn into nuclear fusion butterfly
well you know yeah water for hopeful I
know that sounds really Pollyanna
pie-in-the-sky kind of thing I was kind
of taking it more from the global
population standpoint that as we like
those cells of the butterfly begin to
awaken what happens inside the
caterpillar is that at first the cold
caterpillar cells see this foreign
object inside of itself and they almost
they actually try to quell it or attack
it as being a foreign body however the
vibration of that imaginal cell of the
butterfly is so great that not only does
it not succumb to the attack it actually
begins to cluster with other like
imaginal cells throughout the body of
the caterpillar and as they cluster they
gain critical mass and then to quote
another Star Trek reference and the
Borges would have it resistance is
futile and so then it begins and it
actually goes to a process where it is
kind of gelatinous in that it is neither
caterpillar nor butterfly until the
cluster continues continues and evolves
as the butterfly so taking that metaphor
into humanity as we awaken and in this
vibration of only source existing and we
cluster together we connect with each
other we start embolden each other we as
perhaps the greatest function that any
of us can have is to remind each other
of who we really are as these energetic
beings capable of so much more than we
ordinarily believe that is really good
yeah yeah that's one of the takeaways we
could look at market right here bookmark
it right there yeah remind yes your most
beloved people of who they really are
and who they can be and they can do the
same for us because it's so easy to
forget in this world of a lot of
information
and a lot of it is shock and awe and you
know rightfully separation yeah perhaps
the greatest thing we can do is to
remind one another of who and what we
really are what we really are yeah how
we can tune in to this energy in and
cluster together and then and then
become of a greater force to be reckoned
with
because as more of us clustered together
and as we do so I have to say we're
having one hell of a great time or one
heaven of a great time as the case may
be
yeah because it feels so delicious just
to be in this energy and just free from
the negative self-talk to a great you
know and and all the self-deprecating
stuff that each of us are so accustomed
to doing and literally creating through
neuroplasticity of all things new neural
pathways in our brain that confirm that
we are essentially happy loving good
beings here absolutely graced to be in
this life form because maybe some of the
other life forms maybe aren't so
interesting and being human is you know
top of the food chain for the time being
here and how wonderful is that you know
that we get to enjoy all the nuances of
sound and smell and taste and touch and
contemplating the cosmos exactly and
being self-aware and noticing how we get
to grow and evolve there's a this I
don't want another get to that growth in
evolution
evolution the blizzard the butterfly
what else is covered from I don't know
keep asking some questions so what
happens it's so good so good it probably
is in the fireside chat we just had a
Jordan Peterson he brought up that very
competent people know how to help other
people they know that that brings some
lot of fulfillment and meaning into
people's lives mmm
hundred percent degree some of the best
feeling that we can get and it doesn't
even matter even if you'd selfish
because it makes me feel good it doesn't
you doesn't matter you enjoy being good
to other people because it makes you
feel good exactly stem feel good as well
yeah it's good enlightened self-interest
yeah just you know I I want to change
the entire world or involve with with
the entire world into a place of love
and joy and peacefulness and playfulness
and yeah I just turned the ripe old age
chronological age of 60 go believed you
look so damn good thank you
and I feel marvelous yeah I really god
bless and you know and so part of it for
me is I don't know how much more time I
have on this planet being in a viable
physical vehicle here he'd like you as
long as possible and I'm kind of willing
to stick around as long as I'm really
having a great time good which I'm
hopeful is quite longer than I
originally thought it would be and
having said that I am getting this sense
of of legacy of impact to the extent
that I could not even be barely a
footnote in the history of humanity if
there is something I can do to really
help to make this world a better place
than what I was born into yeah exactly
I'm all in for that exactly I'm all in
for that and oh by the way I've got five
kids yeah so I would love to leave them
as much as possible yeah at with a world
that is substantially more loving
playful and peaceful
and prosperous then what they were born
into and then to the alight and
self-interest peace in all selfishness
there's any possibility of having a new
era of humanity on this planet and I
think there was a small one yeah I am
very much all-in and wanting to
experience it simply for myself yeah
exactly people ask me why do you want to
live longer than your 80 year old body
can handle and I say because
self-interest wise I want to see where
we get as a society how we evolve I
would get there and I don't want to
assure in that new era as well I think
it is important to call it a new era I
think it is because if it's not
specifically identified as something
that is new and different and and better
and again this seems like there's Dogma
attached to it being better but at this
but at the same time it really there's
so many different ways to get there I
thought what you said earlier about
there about there's so many old parts of
the operating system that we will usher
in as part of the new but that's up to
us collectively to figure out what they
are with our own thoughts and our own
energies ourselves to pick those things
and bring them in to what the new
operating system ends up being so ok
yeah for example yeah except ceremony
ceremonies ok you know celebrations are
really important and we get to create
our own so in terms of what the old
world has they have some ceremonies of
your own rites of initiation you know
coming together to celebrate a
particular idea some will call it a holy
day a holiday and we get to create our
own so we get to borrow from that and we
also get to you know the thought process
behind it of bringing more mindfulness a
little more you know it does not every
day needs to be business as usual you
know we could bring in something unique
and special just to us to pay it
- and hopefully celebrate a one
particular aspect of living and have
that be a day or a ceremony that we
invite our our friends into as a way to
both to slow down and to all pay
attention to something that is even more
life and love affirming then perhaps we
see every day so it's the celebration
again again the analogy of the
celebration what are we celebrating when
we wake up celebrating our life our
weight we're celebrating oxygen and food
and water and shelter the basic
physiological needs that we have and
then are we able to celebrate you know
slowing down and telling the other
person that we were able to tune into
this beautiful energy okay I actually
have taken and vows are really important
that's another tool that we use that you
bow I make the world a better boy or
whatever it is whatever we all get to in
our uniqueness yeah get to put that in
our own words based upon what speaks
most of us so one of the things I've
done is that I like to play with words
and I like to have fun is taking a vow
of celibacy yeah celibacy Celebrezze
seed which is about to celebrate at
least one aspect of life yeah every day
yes and it can be just as simple as
waking up and being able to get out of
it yes some people unfortunately don't
even have that capability you know based
on physical impairment so it could be as
simple as that or it could be as simple
as you know what the sun is shining
today and I just saw a flower
yeah that's blossoming and that's
actually one of the side effects that I
notice and by the way I'm a work in
progress like everybody else here so I
you know I'm not exactly coming from on
high here what's on this moment if
knowing are getting everybody
I gotta get the link but but one thing I
notice is when I am in that kind of
unitive only source groove then my sense
of beauty is heightened yeah where
things that if otherwise I may pass
right by as being ordinary seem to take
on a little bit of an extraordinary kind
of hue and aura yeah that was like hmm
yeah that's just and isn't it
unfortunate there's there was this quote
Terence Mckenna
I'm gonna pin for a while last month he
got a good amount of attention online
after I posted it but it was what
Terence Mckenna said was what was
happening to him right around the time
of his death what's which was that he
had finally had the most profound sense
of beauty that he's ever experienced in
his life as an even observing ants
crawling on the ground and light shining
through the Leafs mmm just brought him
to tears
mmm and I don't think it should take us
until the end of our life when we're on
our deathbed to to see that as such a
beautiful part on this earth yeah that's
absolutely true
I don't think we have to wait that long
and I think only the source is gonna
help us know get there yeah I'm gonna do
my part you the test for the best I can
you know your parts so damn oh thank you
your your eyes I mean you you you put me
into a moment of celibacy it's just by
being around me and that is actually
part of the whole thing exactly we are
contagious interconnected beings and we
can start simply another take away you
want to do an action item a call to
action style yeah we actually so on our
media on our website only the source
calm we actually have a few original
videos and one of them is called a
hundreds miles an hour yeah okay and
it's the power of smile
and we literally take off and go behind
the scenes to see what's actually
happening with our neurotransmitters and
biochemistry even when we fake a smile
correct yeah let alone when it becomes
authentic and then our eyes become
involved and then it's more of a
full-bodied experience if you have to
hold a pencil in your mouth they've done
those examples of your teeth because in
your force that's nice right yeah right
that's right and we all know that when
you go to the Safeway or wherever you go
into the you know checkout line you
smile you're gonna get a smile back more
times than not right even when you're in
traffic or walking past people on the
street and that is something that we all
get to pass on and you know see what
kind of smile egde we can get smile is
drop that one in there Ron how true is
this though how true is your feeling
right now from stood that you're getting
conversation but you feel this bites
I feel as vibes but I'm well aware that
you know there's gonna be resistance
like we were talking in the last week
about girls and then what you do people
there's going to be resistance to that
idea you love feathers hey
maybe maybe we should touch on that a
little bit it's how do you get past that
well I put the ball in Ron's Court Ron
how do you get past that just for
yourself just make that look just for
and you know at this point work on it
every day you can't from this loving
harmonious truth one world one vision to
come together you can't deny you can't
take for granted when people say there
is an effort to divide and conquer you
know and we right I don't dismiss that
and I take that seriously and I want to
work and understand people's point of
view that I don't necessarily agree with
but I can only respect him say it was
nice talking to you I'm gonna hang out
with these guys and do other things so
every day yeah every day is the step
towards better loving and caring yes
this is absolutely a practice there are
absolutely tools that each of us can use
and Ron is absolutely right a lot of
people haven't gotten the memo yet and
they are god bless them really
entrenched yeah doing their best to keep
that old world alive because it gives
them some kind of you know empowerment
in their own way they feel they're
better than somebody else in their own
God bless them distorted view of the
true nature of reality I mean it's been
going on so long that all this stuff
like greed violence shame all these
things which cut to the core of our
separation and core to the dysfunction
of our civilization in our society low
self-esteem all of that literally are
bugs of this old system of separation
that have been going on so long
throughout the millennia that we
basically take it as human nature when
in fact what if and this is just the
what if your kids what if is simply a
bug and a symptom of a faulty program
yes and if we're able cyber update big a
big if if we are able software update
install a new OS only source and use at
least our intellectual curiosity because
that is what science is telling us is
the true nature of our physical reality
we all know that behind the scenes our
heart pumps blood throughout our entire
body we don't even have to think about
it generally speaking we're breathing we
don't even have to think about it when
we smile we're not even aware that there
are neurotransmitters firing away from
our brain that are actually and those
neurotransmitters which are not also
aware of or actually manufactured in our
gut biome and so to the extent that we
are eating things that are healthy
things that promote our healthy gut
that's the factory for these
neurotransmitters so if you're eating
crap all day god bless you what's gonna
wind up happening is your inventory of
these neurotransmitters ain't gonna be
so high and what that means is when it's
time to smile as I hey you know because
you just don't have that basis
underneath so this is an amazingly
integrated system with all kinds of new
steps new ways of being that we can do
every single day and just like anything
else it takes 30 to 45 days is what it
seems like to start really carving
indirect new neural pathways to have new
habits and new ways of being more firmly
established you you're nailing it that
the bugs and the old OS the software
update you that you and Ron we're
talking about all those bugs those are
serious bugs and that is how we move
forward with this update
even some something else that I think
that we should talk about is you know
you talk about 30 days 45 days the
amount of time that it's gonna take to
put these habits put these habits into
our daily lives as something that we
live that we live with the smile that we
that we function differently every
single day from from the source I
understand you what are some of these
only the source you know videos and
activities that you guys are
recommending Thank You Paula and also
how do those linked directly to that
self-actualization that collective
actualization sure yeah thanks for
asking Alan yeah so right now we have
five unique original videos on our
website one is talks about the next
human OS and that's kind of like a
corporate manifesto video okay these are
all short form less than three minutes
each so you have at it only the source
com I'm sure the link will be in the
BIOS in bio yo yeah and so there's a
couple of other videos that we have that
are essentially practices that we can
actually engage in what I mentioned was
you know hundreds miles an hour and in
other words called praise the raise
where we just acknowledged the Sun a
little bit every day even on a cloudy
day it's providing for our existence yes
and you know as the video says in its
own kind of exactly inimitable
light-hearted way you know it's the Sun
is absolutely an embodiment of
unconditional love because it shines
know I always seem to do and he used to
be the deity for people all the longest
time exactly and understandably so
correct it provided them with all their
food and light right during the day
right without it yeah our world ends
yeah yeah okay and it's also an exempt a
great example of infinite abundance Q
because no man up close oh no well to
the extent what I meant by that is okay
if I go out in the Sun and I'm Sun
Tanning I'm not taking any less Sun away
from anybody else yeah
yeah yeah so that's what I was saying so
even though I'm taking some in there's
plenty for everybody
that'll knock yourselves out and until
there's someone behind you getting these
right in your shadow ok I'll move over a
little bit yeah plenty of Ron plenty of
room here yeah yeah and we also realize
that to live in a new world we want to
create some new words to point to the
world that we want to live in neologisms
yeah right this has been a really yes
we're in school of thought for me and
for so many other people because you
can't describe the new OS with the old
language exactly so we have a couple of
new ones for you yes one is yes it's
yeses yes it's it's the essence of yes
Ron yes yes it's also also using some
old school words words it's being all in
and going all out don't expand a bit
yeses being all in going all out boys
all out oh and all out so whatever it is
that you're doing whether it's in
relationship or it's at work or is it
this task or whatever it is or even at
play when you're on the slopes or
whatever it is be all in and go all out
and what that does is nothing else
exists and it brings us into a greater
moment of a presence 7/5 just and into
this eternal moment where this is all
that exists right now and Wow yeah so
that's that so the essence is tied to
the present moment oh yeah and it's it's
it's time it's going all all in all out
yeah okay okay cool I like that yes yes
okay so praise praise the raise and and
one hundreds miles an hour
hundreds are a couple of the kind of
exercise type videos and of things that
people can do with a very clear call to
action yeah super clear yeah very simple
yeah the other ones and not much dogma
there are almost no dogma pretty much to
my knowledge who wants to frown like why
would you offer awnings better
so our set at all of these videos are
universal and it also include some
aspect of science underneath exactly to
back up and let people know what's kind
of going on subsurface
in our own chemistry yeah okay because
everything we do is actually completely
integrated with what's going on in the
inside even if it's being on the naked
eye to see right exactly yeah and so
another new word is be weaving be
weaving oh yeah and that is where we
can't readily discern where one ends and
another begins
do you weave it yeah that's what takes
the individualism kind of a little bit
for their way their separation isms
further
well there's both exactly weaving yeah I
mean so we shot that in the redwood
forest up in Occidental oh cool
beautiful place which is a great
metaphor metaphors time yeah a great
metaphor of of our reality in that they
appear to be individual trees yet very
shallowly beneath the forest floor their
roots are completely intertwined and
interconnected yes so are they really
separate trees or are they ultimately
kind of like one organism so once that
in take more carbon end up sharing it
with the ones that get less yeah there's
there's they're speaking there cook with
the communicating with one another and
they're communicating with us I mean
they essentially breathe in our carbon
dioxide and they turn it into oxygen we
breathe in what they exhale
they exhale oxygen we take that in and
it has that kind of beautiful whatever
you call that one reason reason for life
reason for living Rizal River his own
dad 20 that's ranch truck that's Esprit
I love that one yeah that's a good one
um so okay so lessons are yeah so the
new words you know be weaving and as we
end and yes it's got a couple in the
pipeline that we're in the process of
developing I could give you a little
spoiler alert yeah and that kind of goes
towards what we were talking earlier
about our uniqueness yeah and that is
embraces 'im embraces 'm embraces him is
an antonym to racism and specifically
you know it goes beyond tolerance and
acceptance to the celebration
so brave of our diversity great yeah
thank god you're different than me
yeah I love you we have some
similarities and they are so grateful
you're different than me yeah I get to
learn from you I get to relish in your
experience and I also get to be really
curious wow that sounds kinky that turns
you on cool rather than going into
judgment around it oh that turns you on
I and that doesn't turn me on there must
be something wrong with either you or me
it's perfect embraces them embraces and
into new of racism yes yeah so I know
it's timely also we got to get this one
out yeah yeah yeah yeah and another god
you're different from yes I can learn
from you no judgment yeah yeah yeah
another one another one is return 'ti
eternity
yes and that's when we are in a timeless
state again expand a bit so we live life
and we're on the clock okay we're going
through the motions we're doing we're
doing I got to be somewhere in an hour
I'm doing my thing
you know you're doing your thing and
we're on this linear timeline yeah every
now and then we'd get in these moments
we can just look at each other's eye I
just have that sense of connection
yeah and just everything else everything
else melts away and we go into a
timeless state even just for a moment
and then that timeless state that is
returned 'ti return any return 'ti so
it's kind of return and eternity in them
is a point to return to that state is
that why it's called returning because
you're trying to get more people as well
yeah I think that one of the beautiful
side effects of being an only source
consciousness and in that operating
system is that essentially it is
timeless and eternal and we tap in to
that timeless state and my sense is we
do have more linear moments of
timelessness when we are in the new OS
yeah it doesn't mean that time dissolves
although maybe at some point that does
maybe we go past the fourth dimension of
time into the fifth dimension of
whatever that is and you know but
without getting to cosmic around it
it could just simply be enough that we
have more moments of beauty timelessness
and and more moments of extraordinary
nacinda ordinary moments yep
you guys are so on point I love you so
much and your team's yeah so much I'm so
happy that you guys went forward with
neologisms with new words to describe
with the new OS but you know something
that's interesting that we should just
chat about a little bit is that you're
taking old words and you're what I
imagine you guys are doing is you're
writing down these words and then you're
throwing kind of different intros on
prefixes prefixes suffixes exactly
you're just you're you're deer exactly
and soon you're I am that's what I
imagine your activity is right now is
these beautiful what's one of them yeah
nothing suffixes and stuff as I think
that's really good because these words
already mean something to people yes
that's what's good because they already
mean something it helps the racism helps
them migrate right I totally agree with
you um versus um let me give you a
little quick
neologism from Kurt Vonnegut from one of
his books that he wrote with that which
had a science fictional race of aliens
called the tralfamadorians
and so that they were they were they
were famous for knowing how they could
look at an item such as let's say this
wood table and they could tell you the
entire past history the entire present
moment and the entire future of this
table mm-hmm so that's cool yeah so
stuff like that again so it's important
to know that this used to be a tree made
into a table could assembled in this way
with the different color as well in the
different shapes and in the future it
will likely get recycled into some
thing else and so and so just again it
wasn't a word like re like whatever
recycle op elasaur whatever right it
wasn't a new word really it was a
complete it wasn't a new word on the old
for the old understanding with old word
and just adding a prefix or suffix it
was a completely different science
fictional a whole new word holding guard
right maybe that is something that is of
interest as well because sometimes we
might not be able to come up with a
you've got Google's you're like Google
yeah which I guess kind of refers to a
Google pax but yeah it's the same it's
still new enough that it kind of came
out of the blue yeah yeah yeah so maybe
there is some sort of new words that
need to be created that haven't been
written in human language quite yet but
that are in our path that will help us
understand like what is a good word for
the deep empathy with someone else
you know maybe embraces amiss getting
there right things like that but or what
is maybe a word for the the the
understanding of the cosmic scale so
maybe even really get the deep
understanding of how long everything's
been around it really Dwarfs your ego is
there a word for that ego death right
what's what how what exactly right what
are these records that really can
transform people that's been something
that I've been really interested in as
well I you know what I don't have that
monopoly in all new words so let's all
create this new language together
anybody out there if you got any ideas
you know please reach out to us because
it's you know it is a wide open field
yeah I I'm really happy you guys are
going with the new words and even like
you said it's the neologisms when they
relate to older words state with
different prefixes suffixes that
some uh sure in the new OS embraces them
what was it called smile of bulls
what's mileage I miss mileage yeah I get
something more so mileage in your life
yeah how many miles have you smiled
today yeah mileage we have to put these
words in the bio as well we have to put
kissing analogies and the words in the
bio as well
all of them so we will do that for
everyone just so that thank you okay so
the things that we've been talking about
have been the tools that you guys are
developing this last bit the tools that
you're developing to help people become
more actualized as well as the
collective more actualized so you listed
the video content so this is videos and
activities that you write amend people
to do what else yeah thank you so we are
starting the package now some of the
video content and some other exercises
into a form of online courses so that it
actually becomes much more of a learning
because even as Ron mentioned earlier
you know there are practices that people
need to do every single day and new ways
of you know playing with this vehicle
and having greater influence over how we
experience life through breathing sound
movement in bhau's there are a number of
things that are highly predictable in
terms of not only shifting our energy
rather quickly
because that's what science has it
though you know thank you very much and
whoever created this thing and as well
as just getting that kind of
reinforcement and and some degree of
accountability to help ensure that real
transformation occurs because we want
people to live the most amazing life
they possibly can and so online courses
live events where we kind of look at
live events if online courses are kind
of like the old version of like that the
CD or the the music compilation the the
live event is like a concert
because that's where you go and you know
you are actually connected with all
these other people simultaneously so you
get into the group field yeah that you
don't get when you're in not an online
course yeah
to the same degree yeah and that way we
actually get to offer some processes
where people get to interconnect with
each other yes and that helps even
further with the integration so now it's
just not a person sitting behind a
computer learning how to breathe and
expand and and and make sounds and and
move in ways that expand their own
energy field but that the people around
them may not quite have gotten that memo
yet and they you know there's can feel a
little isolated by you know where is the
rest of the party you know what was the
word be be weaving be weaving and
weaving yeah yeah yeah yeah and so in
person offering up some events about
exercises where people can you know
connect I to I are at the heart you know
maybe do a little energy exercise always
I start feeling that interconnectivity
that actually substantially increases
the the integration makes it more real
because you're doing it now with a lot
of other people it also helps to create
community which is something that people
really want and these cell phones of
ours are really like a double-edged
sword and in some ways it really
enhances communication in other ways
it's a little divisive in terms of
creating real community when it's a lot
easier for people to go and play candy
crush or whatever they're doing on their
phone yeah and and not you know
connecting with others yeah it's much
more difficult to go to a live event
where you're forced out of your comfort
zone to be weave with people invite
actually that yeah we go beyond worth
way more yeah crushing candies yeah
exactly any other than the comfort zone
piece I mean anytime we grow we're
typically growing beyond what was
comfortable exactly and yet we can also
create a really warm and playful and
fire
yeah to have that experience in whether
it's on online courses or whether it's
in person and the third piece to our our
stool here is ongoing integration
support by coaches and counselors
healers whatever it is that individuals
may have in their own life experience
that I wanna say is unique to them but
certainly personal to them and may not
be addressed in a group setting so there
are all kinds of people with all kinds
of ptsds and various forms related to
either something that would be in under
the me to category or something that
happened at work with discrimination or
you know a troubling childhood or
physical issues things that may not be
fully addressed in a group setting you
know it's like no soul left behind you
know we want anybody who is interested
in getting support and or further
integration beyond the event or beyond
the online course because God blesses a
lot of great stuff out there but one of
the things we've noticed that may be
lacking in a lot of cases is you know
how to get beyond the weekend high you
have this great experience I've been to
the seminar well my heart is open the
life is amazing I go back to work and
you know it's the daily activity exactly
I have to come with a smile edge there's
a whole bunch and again no Dogma pick
and choose what works what works for you
and the good news is there are literally
infinite ways to awaken to that which is
already ever-present within us yes so
you're offering some in ways that are
humorous and and light-hearted and
accessible but you know what if you have
things that work for you
maybe you should reach out and let us
know and we can make you a whole lot
activity out of it and share with the
following you know what everyone exactly
you know I think that of just what
you're practicing yeah because we you
know we all have pieces to a puzzle that
can have such little that new era of
humanity exactly we all have a role to
play so I'm inviting you all whatever
your inspiration is
please share yeah create with us the new
era of this operating systems of only a
source because it is it's it's gonna be
completely like you said there's no
dogmas different people can contribute
differently to what this new OSS and
let's share whatever is true to people
in their way of unleashing themselves to
the world let's bring that to other
people through these different
activities ok ok so if I bring in one
thing of ancient wisdom yeah let's see
ok so one piece of ancient wisdom has it
that whether it's the second coming of
Christ or Buddha's reappearance on this
planet it comes in the form of a group
it's not an individual so that means
that any one of you us could be part of
the second coming of Christ and or the
second appearance of the Buddha
consciousness on our planet
so just to offer that up as you know the
old school would have it it's got to
come in the form of an individual being
it's actually it can easily come in the
form of a collective yeah yeah and it
might even be that the collective
assuring it in collectively ends up
affecting more than an individual maybe
maybe because with the technology with I
can give an example of it seems like if
with potential technology like
blockchain that could have been made by
one person and if it was made by one
person then that could usher in a whole
new era with one person's effect
into that whole new era of how people
interacting yeah so so that that that
can also be fairly interesting but and
individuals certainly have their own
contribution to make absol so blockchain
may be one contribution you know Google
may be another you know people are
coming things from different angles
yeah and then it's just simply a matter
of how do we put all these pieces
together in a way that is interconnected
holistic and inspiring to us all yeah
you really radiate the love you really
radiate to dance the energy you you're
infectious oh oh thank you and I got to
tell you in all humility and and
vulnerability you know I'm human I've
got plenty of moments of contraction and
just wondering WTF yeah so you caught me
on a good day
yeah and I'm also aware that this is a
migratory process because as energy
beings one thing that we know energy
does is it modulates so it's kind of
like a sine wave type of frequency so
we're gonna have moments that feel like
dips even if for no reason that are we
have low blood sugar
you know yeah let alone a thought
crosses our mind that feels a little
self-deprecating or challenging or they
didn't do what I wanted them to do when
they said they would do it and then the
energy drops so what we can do is is
kind of steer this energetic sine wave
vibration to hopefully a higher spectrum
so that we have higher highs and higher
lows in our life we have the lows but
maybe even our lows can become higher
than they used to be yeah as our highs
in fact you know I used to be a money
manager in the stock market go believe
and did that for 18 years the financial
industry why you're who you are today
well it's one of the reasons I guess
let's say so and what's interesting
about that is the classic definition of
a bull market is a series and a trend of
higher highs and higher lows
so even when people are making money
hand over fist in a
bull market they're still gonna be down
days and so that's something that we can
all take the heart that even if we can
hopefully have a personal bull market if
you will are our own personal stock
continues to rise as our energies kind
of just continue to hopefully lighten up
and feel more delicious and delightful
and playful and loving on a regular
basis we're still gonna have moments
that aren't gonna feel that way
interesting so we can even break this
down mathematically as a stock so if
you're let's say your x-axis is time
your age axis is age and then your
y-axis is your overall sense of
flourishing let's say if we experienced
over let's say after we get to like 20
or so at that point we seem to be fairly
decently calm more conscious of
happiness and sadness and our overall
flourishing at that point then we get to
decide whether or not we kind of
skyrocket through these activities and
through these ways that we get to become
our fullest potential and and in really
drink from this unification theory of
everything and we can then rise up until
the point where our lows even seem like
they're super high still throughout rest
of our life versus if we're living down
here later at our life in terms of our
overall flourishing exactly I really
enjoy how we can break it down like a
stock buffet yeah and now consider the
possibility of she's not into a video
yeah that's a good one thank you for
that I love that grass I missed that one
yes like a stock yeah mature treat your
life like a stop the personal bull
market the personal bull market yeah I
actually wrote about it I you know I
didn't I actually wrote a book once upon
a time called inner security and
infinite wealth merging self-worth and
net worth and I took my the principles
from the financial world and I couldn't
because I loved playing with words I
couldn't help but notice how many words
in the financial industry have dual
meanings that have greater than
financial meaning
and so wrote this book and notice that
there were eight everyday very simple
financial concepts that have greater
than financial meaning to create
security and wealth beyond money so
that's what a kind of a knell like words
like will thrust and appreciation oh
yeah those are huge yeah they all have
application in the financial world
they all have application in creating
the kind of wealth that money can't buy
so interesting yeah and I bet if you
look up appreciation only the second or
the third definitions related to finance
first definitions related to humans yeah
yeah yeah yeah and an appreciation has a
lot of components to it it has the the
heart based sense of gratitude and it
also has the mental capacity of
understanding so I can appreciate what
you're saying yeah sure yeah and so it's
real and of course appreciation is
nothing more than an increase of value
yep yeah oh I love it yeah okay let's
see this has been so good we'll
definitely have to do you know another
whole beautiful session again to really
dive you know even an even more
interesting paths of all this and to
help make more content for only the
source absolutely oh thank you oh by the
way I want a gap I can come back for one
moment here I go ahead Thanks yeah when
we talked about that graph and it was a
great graph I because I could visualize
it so you're in your 30s or whatever you
are right there are a lot of Millennials
out there they're forming families right
now yeah what if the kids that are being
born now were born into this world with
this kind of understanding from the very
beginning perfect segue into exactly the
next question thank you and the the
essence of this next question I wanted
to ask was about how what is the sort of
ideal I always ask it in the specific
way I like talking
the story leading up to the question
which is we've done such a good job as a
civilization to stamp out these humans
into the world with enough water and
food and basic physiological needs we've
done a pretty good job of doing that
there are still certain parts in the
world that need a little bit development
so they didn't suffer as much but we're
kind of missing a little chip on given
this I give given you guys at only
source this whole analogy before but
that little chip that's missing maybe on
the shoulder area of the human mold it
could be that essence of what you're
describing right now which is what if
these Millennials that the Millennials
that are 25 to 35 that are having kids
right now and birthing them into the
world what if they could enrich their
child with with adding that missing chip
of the shoulder on that mold and that
and those activities might be the thing
like thus mileage like it might be
things like in embrace ISM the weaving
you know praising the Rays right right
and there's a whole bunch stuff yeah so
but so what are these collectively what
are these activities or experiences that
we're gonna describe to the children so
that way they can grow into this new OSS
optimally as possible and again it's the
it's the responsibility of the parent
that you it is you are the God of the
child so it's up to you to communicate
these things to the child and get them
ready for the world that they're about
to live it yes and ideally it extends to
the teachers it extends to you notice it
to the environment and so that's really
what excites me is that we and I think
the tipping point could be a lot sooner
than when otherwise believe that there's
a whole spate of new kids coming out
into the world that can get this
awareness from the very beginning if I
could kind of have it already and maybe
we already had it and it got socialized
out of us you know because of being an
instructor with our parents living in
the old OS live
in all the fears and all the constraints
and all the scarcity consciousness and
all the rest that has been you know
layered upon us that we have to
essentially you know unlearn yeah or
otherwise release and shed yeah I like
that
unlearn and release and chef kind of the
old OS the old aspects of the old OS
that are not benefiting yeah and they're
gonna you know and run are it is hard
hard that's why I love it yeah it's hard
I think a lot of people are in there and
they understand this inside but the
biggest challenge is its difficulty and
said right why okay so you consider a
thala a 10,000 mile journey starts in
the first mile so you start wherever you
are and that's the good thing that maybe
it's not necessarily a matter of going
from zero to Nirvana in two seconds yeah
it may simply be a matter of if I could
take my energy and just move it a little
bit yes then all of a sudden I realize
okay maybe like kids walking maybe I
take maybe it's crawling before walking
before running yes and it but there's a
compounding and building up on each
other one more mile of smilers yeah yeah
please no ended up getting a lot of
people are worse off going out than
where they came in you know what they
knew is it jives a young person yeah
right so right the bugs
Sophia's bugs too and yes and those bugs
are insidious yes and even if you think
I'll speak for myself even when I think
I've reached a certain level of
awareness and awakening' whatever you
want to call it you know what I always
find the way where I get humbled by that
bug that shows up and I start beating
myself up or I just start going into a
place of fear yeah a round you know why
is the world
way it is yes and you you weave let's
loop this all the way to the beginning
before we end is that at the beginning
we talked about relationships and it can
be in relationship with your kids it can
be your relationship with your partner
it can be relationship with your parents
but the bugs tend to show up a lot in
those areas of time because when you see
a stranger on the street you're you're
typically not as willing to you know
push that button for you have oh you're
more likely to be you know stranger
friendly to that person you know be some
have some smiling or that person but
then when you get home you have a little
bit smile äj--
but then you're spending an hour with
that person and then it might with your
kids your kids might you know run and
like break something or like you know
stomp on your foot or whatever to test
you or play with you et cetera so just
to bring you back to the beginning that
it's interesting how a lot of the bugs
lie in the moments of the most intimate
with our closest people and then that's
actually interestingly where we can
usher in a lot of the new os's within
those those moments that are the bugs of
the relay close relationship right
exactly and if we can remember to be
gentle with ourselves yes and each other
in that process it can make a big
difference and you know really at
literally at the end of the day we only
have one life partner and that's
ourselves yeah
where we hey right yeah so with that
please if is any takeaway just please be
gentle with yourself yeah you know
because at deeply humble to how
insidious this program is that we've
been socialized into and we all have a
litany of experiences that confirm how
difficult life is how separate we are
from one another
even if it's completely ultimately one
massive illusion and that the true
nature of our physical reality is that
we are interconnected as energy waves or
dancing subatomic particles however you
want to describe the physical nature of
reality and that really is the truth of
it and how can we utilize that with
curiosity and what's possible here and
my sense is just like has been promised
in some of the the old scriptures that
there can be a new era there can be
something that's a heavenly existence
here and you know it's it's time science
is actually showing up and the bugs are
being so pronounced in their
demonstration that you know that the
choice actually is becoming clearer and
clearer complacency really is becoming
less of an option I love it okay so last
couple thoughts before we close out is
let's ask you a couple of our simulation
questions so first off and we'll try and
wrap these up fast but do you believe
that there is a global ruling elite yeah
I kind of do and you know I'm sure
they're very proud of themselves who are
they that I I can't really know I mean
one would think that it's people who
have substantial influence over
financial wealth and substantial
influence therefore over governmental
policies yeah and as to who they are by
name yeah I really don't know so much
other than just like any just like oh
god bless you guys just like old cells
of the caterpillar you know there is a
new vibration that is seeking to emerge
and it is so delightful that it cannot
be denied it will not be denied
and these power brokers may actually
whether they go down kicking and
screaming or they go down in a flame of
Oh finally a relieved of the burden of
having not to try to control everything
all the time which takes up a lot of
energy yeah believe it or not yeah
should one endeavor to join the global
elite would you join any club that would
have you as a member I don't know maybe
maybe I mean I've had one possibility
there are numerous ways in which we can
all be evolving into a new era and one
of them could possibly be getting
together with this global elite and
offering them the tools of awareness and
consciousness because they more than
anybody one they know what money can't
buy because I got the [ __ ] ton of it
pardon the expression and they know what
it doesn't buy yeah and everything that
money is prescribed as some kind of like
you know the virtue of like you know God
and Carnac and that if you have enough
of it you're gonna have a happy
existence thing they know what money
can't buy that's right because I have it
yeah yeah and they know what power can't
buy him they know all the areas in life
that have not been cured yeah by
whatever they have going on yeah exactly
and so having this piece and just
dropping into that is something that can
allow for them to open their hearts but
the end connect with people in ways
they've never connected before which is
absolutely one of the beauties of being
incarnate as a human yes yes okay next
up is are we alone in the cosmos
I find it hard to believe that somehow
that there's a you know that there's not
even a multiverse that if we're just a
universe I imagined actually that this
entire universe may simply be like a
dingleberry on the ass of some massive
being that we can't even contemplate
that is filled and comprised of
multiverses and having all kinds of
experiences that we can't even begin to
fathom right now yeah yeah and yet
somehow our problems seem to be really
big yeah okay good a good answer like
that one it's super short and sweet and
to the point that was good yeah okay and
I hope I pass this quiz these questions
in advance that was that was a really
good answer and we could it will unpack
that one potentially more in our next
convo okay next up is are we in a
computer simulation we may be we may be
in fact given that ultimately it's just
an energetic field of energy that we all
are vibrating at various frequencies
creating this illusion of solidity when
in fact it's simply nothing more than
energy vibrating and a denser frequency
frequency I've been wondering whether
all of this existence is actually a
dream in the mind of some greater
intelligence that is dreaming all of us
up simultaneously and somehow we just
haven't been informed that none of this
is real yeah yeah and so we're kind of
buying our own essentially so what are
these misperception misperception yeah
yeah you meant you reference this at the
beginning so I figured your answer would
be somewhat along these
because you mentioned the higher being
the creator of whatever we are
experiencing whether that be the
simulator of the universe or the creator
of the universe or whatever of the
multiverse is whatever that be you
mentioned at the being so I figured you
didn't have a okay an interesting answer
at the end which you know you you did
okay and all right
lastly uh-huh is what is the most
beautiful thing
I would say that we get to exist in this
world
but that is incredibly beautiful and in
this form also implies that the
capabilities that we have that come with
being in this form so the ability to
taste chocolate for example to have sex
or to have sex exactly
to to grow and not be locked in so that
I actually feel like even in this
lifetime
I've been reincarnated several times in
the same body so that my life as a money
manager in the stock market completely
separate life my high school and
completing high school completely
separate elementary school completely
separate and to have that spectrum of
experience which is so incredible and
now to be at a chronological age of 60
where there are moments where I am very
much feeling like a teenager and even
acting like one erasing lis so yeah it's
amazing to be able to slide up and down
this time spectrum and that I know kids
in their 20s who can also do the same
and access like wisdom far beyond their
years and so maybe some of you are
watching right now point being is we
have this facility and and and so I I
know I'm saying that there is like all
these nuances to this what is the most
beautiful thing in the world but one of
the things that is an aspect of that is
our ability to awaken yeah and to grow
to looks
to open our hearts and maybe you know in
a word to love to have that vibration of
love whether it's for that piece of
chocolate or if the Golden State
Warriors and Steph Curry popping threes
from midcourt yeah or or whether it's
you know just again being able to have
just amazing beautiful orgasmic teeth
rattling the light yeah yeah I love your
answer to that the just being and then
also growing yeah it's amazing okay Wow
such a powerful session I'm blessed to
be able to pass time with you Alan I
love your brother your fabulous see your
fabulous you might offer everybody a
gift just okay so we just recently had
our first event it was mostly a private
event in New York City and a calorie
that was featuring these amazing
indonesian gongs
called gamilons and one of the things
that does help to shift our energy field
reliably this sound yes whether it's
internally generated or externally
coming our way and those gongs
are amazing and the fellow who put them
together is actually the antithesis of a
starving artist in that his his is
showing his exhibition is now going to
the Smithsonian Wow from this place just
to let you know okay so be an artist you
never know you could actually get the
kind of support that this gentleman his
name is Aaron Taylor Kufner and he has
provided us with an mp3 song these are
actually robotically controlled gongs
and these gongs are formed in orchestras
to have six or seven in a cluster and
he's created an mp3 for us or mp4
whatever it is it's an audio that I
would love to offer anybody who wants to
be activated through some of these
amazing celestial gongs that will shift
energy fish sizzle and so if you just
bushes so could I drop that okay he's a
little lost in flowers I did okay yeah
so anyway yeah so Julia bodily control
robotic controlled so he actually does
it off his iPad and and so did he
actually go in the town he took he made
them oh yeah oh yeah he made them he you
know he shaped them he banged them out
he dipped them in acids whatever it was
literally being trained by the ancients
in Indonesia so yeah yeah came back in
the top you can't he came back and
create he created them and he developed
a software program to play them
robotically and he actually has songs
pre-programmed that a playlist of gongs
going in various sounds on me it is
amazing it's it's they're beautiful to
see and amazing to listen to and if you
just reach me at Stu at only the source
calm that's my email address you can
find me on my website our website as
well I see you as to you exactly I'm
alphabetical as to you and you know and
you know well even have probably have it
on Facebook as well but if you want your
own copy of it and everything you know
come say hello and if you got any new
words or any practices that help you to
just open your heart and mind to the
beauty of our existence please let me
know and maybe we get to co-create it
together put them into video exactly and
incorporate them into online coursework
or live event practices because we all
have you know pieces to a puzzle here
that can be I have I don't know what it
looks like yeah I have an inkling yeah
as to what it can feel like
kinesthetically
and
it brings a great smile huge smile yeah
yeah yeah exactly we have a little touch
and feel of what we think and and a
little bit of goose bump yeah yeah
participate yeah all we're gonna throw
all these different neologisms oyster
for new words all these different
activities we're gonna pop into the bio
for you guys to check out reach out
against to at only the source calm we're
gonna put his email and the bio as well
so you guys can contribute activities
this has been such a pleasure we've
covered so many different amazing topics
and grounds we're definitely gonna have
to unpack more on our next conversation
go check out the content again links in
the bio only the source.com go check out
the content that they have on their site
it's so so enriching again huge shout
out to River Studios for hosting us in
their beautiful space thank you rev
thank you
Thank You Dulce um thank you Ron Vargas
for crushing it behind the TriCaster and
robotic cameras awesome job Ron our
producer and director and thank you guys
for tuning in at home if you guys have
found any of this content to be useful
please like comment subscribe share it
with other people we would love for us
to continue propagating this message
across the world and lastly if you guys
would like to support us we have a
patreon the links gonna be in the bio
you get tons of cool membership benefits
like you get access to conversations
with our guests you get access to
exclusive content you get access to
early access to live events and yeah
plenty more benefits so please do check
out checks out on patreon again thank
you so much for tuning in we'd greatly
appreciate you stood thank you so much
and thank you for having me rather so
much love ya thanks so much love ya